so a couple years ago i applied for a
data science job at google
and it was a disaster keep watching and
i'll tell you all the story
i'm richard and this is richard undata
[Music]
alright so in my last video i gave some
tips about how to get a data science job
and i mentioned that from my own
personal experience i've generally found
it
pretty easy to get jobs there have been
a few
exceptions along the way there and the
most memorable
of all of them was google i mentioned
this in my video
and i got a couple requests that came in
asking me to tell my
experience interviewing with google so i
figured you know what this is a fun
story some of you out there might find
it useful
some of you might find it entertaining
who knows maybe some of you will find it
both of those things
so i'm gonna tell that story before i do
that my usual asks
hit the subscribe button to my channel
if you haven't already for all kinds of
content just like this
smash the like button because that
really does help my content reach a
larger audience
also i will have a link in the
description of this video to my patreon
account
so if you guys are willing to support me
that way that would be enormously
appreciated
so first of all just a little bit of
background on me
so when i was in school and in the
couple years just getting out of school
i never really had a lot of interest in
working for the big tech firms or the
fang companies that is
facebook apple amazon netflix google
and i mean these are great companies and
everything and i really do understand
the appeal
but it just wasn't something that i was
personally interested in
and for a few reasons i mean number one
i live in the detroit area
that's where all my friends and family
are for the most part anyway
and those companies don't have a huge
presence over here
and it's just a thing for me personally
if i have to weigh between some big
career move and staying close to my
relationships here
my family my friends i'm always going to
err on the side of my family and friends
so that's one thing and the other part
of it is
that culture that you get ingrained in
over there
where it's very workaholic based i mean
i know some people who work at google
i know some people at apple and
generally they tell me pretty similar
things
you're kind of living to work at least
in the short term
and honestly the the whole concept of
just
pouring that many hours of your life
every week into one single company
is not something that i've ever been
interested in i highly prefer
i work for 40 to 45 hours a week at
whatever company i have around here and
then in my spare time i'll do other
things i'll enjoy
uh spend time with my family and friends
do my own side projects
whatever it may be i just don't like
working all that much for one single
company
you might but that's just me all that to
say i was never
super pumped about working for any of
these companies in the first place
but i had a buddy who's over at google
and he would always tell me a lot about
it like oh man it's
you should totally apply over here it's
so much fun over here you're in sunny
california
you'll learn so much you can take the
experience you've gathered here
if you leave a few years later you can
take it anywhere else
and i mean that's a totally valid point
not that i was super interested but i
kind of went along with it
just to kind of get this guy out of my
hair so i said all right yeah if you
want to refer me
go for it and so he did and it's my
understanding that
google gets tons and tons of
applications from all around the globe
every single day
but if one of their employees refers you
you sort of get moved to the top of
their stack
so a few days later one of the
recruiters did get a hold of me
and they said i would be a good fit for
a data scientist position
and they gave me this questionnaire to
fill out first kind of as a screening
measure and the questionnaire was pretty
straightforward
it asked me just previous applied
statistics methodologies that i've
implemented in the past
how i've gotten data in the past and the
data quality
issues that you kind of run into from a
practical standpoint
pretty straightforward stuff also my top
technical skills and how i rank my
capabilities in all of them
so whatever i did all that turned it in
nothing to it well then a week later
a recruiter from over there got a hold
of me to set up a google hangouts
interview
now one thing i really do have to hand
it to google on
is when they do their interviews they
are very
organized and very transparent about it
so they basically told me up front this
is going to be a seriously technical
interview
um the things we're going to focus on
are going to be applied
stats and programming capabilities
and they're also very transparent about
the criteria that they're using to
evaluate you
so they're basically looking at four
different things and that's stats
knowledge
your intuition about data related
problems and data in general
programming capabilities and then how
googly
you are which basically means how good
of a culture fit you are
and i had a week's time up front but i
barely prepared for this interview at
all
like if i remember correctly i took this
interview
at like 5 p.m on a day in which i was
taking half the day off of work
and then in the second half of that day
like after lunch
i started going back through some old
course materials i did in school for
stats
but that was really the extent of all
the preparation that i did for this
interview like
basically nothing so i got to the
interview
and then the very first question was
some kind of coding related question
um and i gotta be honest i don't
remember these questions
at all there are some major themes here
and there that i remember from these
from these questions and how i
felt about the questions after the fact
but unfortunately if you came to this
video
looking for specific google interview
questions
i don't have any of those for you i do
remember the first question was
just a basic coding question and when i
say basic
it wasn't super elementary but it wasn't
super crazy or advanced or hard either
and the guy asked me right off the bat
like what language i feel the most
comfortable coding in
and i told him r and he said okay well
for any of these questions you can go
ahead and use
r and the whole time we had the shared
google
doc that was open so he could see my
thought process and the things that i
was writing down
so there was that the next question was
this applied stats question and i don't
remember all the details about it but i
do remember
it was something that could be modeled
using a binomial distribution
and he went on to ask some questions
about like what do you do for a
confidence interval both in the large
sample
and the small sample cases as well as
the behavior the estimate and the
confidence intervals
if you have a p-hat that is the estimate
of the
of the parameter you're trying to look
at here
if that's close to zero or to one
so there's those questions but then
there was a third question
and he told me there were multiple parts
to it but there were only like
three or four minutes left in this
interview so
it was really i gave a few thoughts on
like part a
of a three-part question and then the
interview just
just had to end because we were out of
time after this interview
i gotta be honest i had no idea
whatsoever how i did
like i knew i was maybe a little slow on
the first couple questions but that
generally i had all the right answers
but because i was slow
i barely even got to the third question
at all
so i knew that part of it kind of sucked
uh
but you know a week went by and then i
was sitting at my job and then i
received an email
saying hey can we give you some feedback
about your interview at 1pm
i said sure so then the recruiter calls
me on the phone
and they tell me okay richard you did a
great job so
we'd like to fly you out to mountain
view to the google headquarters
and have you do a full-blown day of
on-site interview over there
for those of you who are overseas
mountain view
is in northern california it's in the
san jose
area of california so at this point my
mind is kind of blown
right like all this started because my
buddy was telling me i should apply
there and now
all of a sudden i'm flying to the other
side of the country pretty much
uh in order to do this interview so all
of a sudden this is getting pretty
serious
and so the way they structure their
interviews there
is at least this is how they did it for
me there are
four interviews each of them lasts an
hour
and actually the way it worked with me
is you had the first interview
and then there's lunch and then you have
the three interviews after lunch
so they gave me two weeks of prep for
this
and then the interview was going to be
on a friday and i probably
prepped a little bit more for this one
but not all that much so i would do an
hour and evening here and there
and the flight from detroit to san jose
is right around four and a half to maybe
five hours
so i was prepping on things like doing
some r code here and there
reading my old applied stats stuff
pretty much consistently the whole time
but nothing too seriously intense so the
morning of the interview
i wake up in the hotel i'm feeling good
i'm ready to fight dragons
i mean really what i was doing was
fighting dragons with a dime-sized
toothpick
because i didn't do much prep work but
regardless i felt ready for this thing
now i do have to mention of course
google's
campus is absolutely gorgeous like from
a landscape
perspective it's in an absolutely
beautiful just
rolling hills type of area the campus is
full of
souvenir shops and museums it really
is huge too i mean it can be kind of
mind-blowing if you're used to working
in
like a little office building where you
have your parking lot and your building
and that's it
it's nothing like that with google or
facebook or any of these other tech
firms
and obviously i can't do a video about
google without talking about the food
the food was awesome
so a lot of you probably know this but
google
has these cafeterias there where they're
basically serving food
i want to say 24 hours but basically
around the clock
and obviously they're doing this uh just
because it makes it that much more
difficult for people working there to go
home
it's a lot easier to you know you're
working you eat
you work some more so they're doing that
for a particular reason but
regardless there's a lot of food and it
was really good
then i go in for the interviews and you
come in
and there's this lobby and it was packed
full of people
who were waiting to go into their
interviews for various positions
so they grab me and like i said there's
four interviews to this process
and when i look back on it the first
interview was the worst of all of them
at least i think you got in there and
the first question was some kind of
conditional probability
question and this wasn't any stats 101
level stuff
no this was some serious math stats type
of stuff that
you know maybe had i been in school at
the time with
the math stat stuff a little fresher in
my head
that i could have answered a little bit
more clearly but
it wasn't good then there was some
question about the cdf of a distribution
that came up a little bit later
and it was just awful like have you ever
been in school
and then you see this problem like
usually in the back of an exam or
something
and you're literally looking at it and
you have no idea how to even start it
i remember that feeling a couple of
times here and there when i was in
school
and it was exactly like that the second
interview as i remember
was pretty heavy on applied statistics
and this one was
pretty similar overall to the one that i
did over
uh the google hangouts interview like i
remember there was some
topics that came up about counts and
rates going back and
forth between the two and just the
poisson and exponential distributions
uh putting these things into a
multivariate context like again i'm
very hazy on the specifics here just
because of how long ago this was
i remember this interview wasn't too bad
but then i got into the third interview
and this is when my ass
started getting kicked all over again
like the first question on that one was
very coding heavy um like once again
we're not talking your straight
comp sci 101 stuff like this was some
actual like
heavy stuff again it was using r i think
there was a sequel question that was in
there too but it was some real
uh creating algorithms using r
and i remember i was getting pretty
stumped by this
up until like 40 minutes in or so when
eventually they moved into some more
applied stats heavy questions
now how i did on these was kind of hit
or miss like there was a question about
regularization like what's the
difference between ridge regression and
lasso
when do you use each mathematically
what's going on there's a question about
feature selection and what
happens when you have covariates that
are pretty uh
heavily correlated like what happens to
the covariates that you keep
uh so stuff like that then i got to the
fourth interview and this one started
out pretty good
uh they asked me how you explain
concepts like p-values
um conducting multiple hypothesis tests
and bonferroni corrections and things
like that
and i taught stats for a little bit
while i was in doing my master's degree
so explaining these sorts of concepts
wasn't something i had
any kind of problem with but then they
threw this finance related question at
me
and i don't remember any of the details
about the problem because
they kept throwing just one piece of
information at it after another after
another there was like six or seven
different variables i remember to this
problem
and i mean this was a real serious
applied sort of problem
and once again it's one of those
problems where like i was looking at it
and i i legitimately had no idea where
to even start
and the problem with a google interview
is it's not like
exactly like how it is in school where
sometimes maybe you'll get a problem
like that but
you'll see it and then you'll skip to
another problem that you know how to do
you can't do that in a google interview
because
you can't so if you can't answer one
question
they're just not going to move on to the
next one right then
they are going to want to see what your
thought process is
and that's one of the things they're
evaluating you on like even if you can't
answer the problem all the way
they want to know what's on your mind
honestly with this problem i mean my
mind was so
jumbled from everything that was going
on it was challenging even to articulate
all the hazy stuff that was going on in
my mind
so that that interview was just a
complete and utter catastrophe
like i i came out of this interview
feeling like my brain got hit by a bus
this was on a friday then the weekend
passed and i got to like monday or
tuesday
and the recruiter called me on the phone
and told me no
i did not pass my final interview with
google
and so here we are the recruiter told me
you can apply again after a year
and i remember just as i went through
the process i was starting to get kind
of hyped up about it like
before i wasn't interested in it and i
mean to this day i'm not
but while i was going through the
process i'm like okay i could i could
really see this right
like the money's really good the point
about it's great experience that you can
get now
you might as well get the experience now
and you can go wherever you want later
all those are really valid points and
this story is really fun to tell it's
fun to tell people uh like over drinks
and dinner or whatever
um but it's never been something that
i've been particularly interested in
going back to
just because i'm happy with where i am
right now
uh just not really interested in trying
again with google
and again google is a wonderful company
for those of you who are
interested in it it's just again not
something i was
really ever super into myself it really
does require
prep like when you're in school there's
a lot of things that you will learn
but over time you're going to forget it
if you're not applying it and using it
from the day to day
and honestly you learn so much while
you're in school there's absolutely no
way in any job in the world
that you're going to use everything that
you've learned all the time
so if you're really interested in a job
at google
you have to really want it and you
really have to do the work up front to
prepare yourself
but if you come from a good background
you really know your stuff and study it
up
again if you want it bad enough i think
you can get it
now there are several reasons why i
decided to share this story on here with
you guys
number one was it was requested so
hopefully somebody out there finds it
useful or funny or whatever
but the other reason is i do want to
make it clear with my channel
that i don't profess to be a data
science guru
and honestly anybody out there who calls
themself a guru in data science
is lying to you for their own ego or
because they're trying to sell you crap
there's tons of stuff out there in this
field that i don't personally know
and the same could be true of virtually
anybody in the community
and i've had instances where i've
applied for jobs and i've not gotten
them
you just heard a story about it now
maybe this one would have been different
had i
done more prep work up front to put
myself in a better position um
who knows not really something i think
about but maybe it would maybe wouldn't
but have been in the data science world
for close to six years now
and i have learned a lot as i've gone
along the way that i wish i could have
told myself
six or seven or eight years ago and
that's why i use this channel to share
those things i know and the things i've
learned with you guys
so you're better educated and better
informed
so i'll leave it all there thanks
everybody for uh for listening to the
story
again hope you enjoyed it if you did hit
the like button
share this video leave me a comment down
below
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future until then
richard on data